[Música]
siempre me consideraba una persona
observadora y curiosa viene muy bien con
el tema del tex la curiosidad
el recuerdo más antiguo que tengo de
esta curiosidad y de esta capacidad de
observación se remonta a cuando vivía en
la habana en el jardín de la casa mi
madre veía pasar los niños y las niñas
mayores que yo tendríais unos 34 años
supongo hacia la escuela me parecía la
palabra escuela tan linda wta y ese
lugar tan bello tan imaginado yo nunca
había ido pero mi mamá mi papá siempre
me decían hijo mío algún día irás algún
diras porque no sólo de pan vive el
hombre pues bien ese día llegó yo fui a
mi escuela llegué allí estaba tan
contento tan ilusionado no sentaron
alrededor de unas mesitas
qué emocionante qué lindo no cuántas
cosas nuevas y uno de los chicos que
estaba allí
cuando quería estar allí en el cole se
quita un zapato lo tira hacia arriba el
zapato hace una trayectoria parabólica
yo no sabía entonces esas cosas y me
cayó en la cabeza me puso a llorar
empieza a llorar la que estaba al lado
en el final
al final la clase se acabó en apenas 25
minutos y todo para la casa no ahí se
acabó la curiosidad por el cole pero
bueno al día siguiente volvimos me gusta
muchísimo mis hijas familia sabe cuándo
vamos ahí me gusta ir a mi escuela a mi
escuelita no siempre en mi memoria van
los amigos de entonces las maestras y
los maestros entonces y bueno es tan
lindo volvernos a esos lugares y de
hecho esa persona que tiró el zapato
ahora trabaja allí y bueno llegas las
brasas le cuenta la batalla interno y
nos reímos en definitiva las cosas que
tiene la vida también tengo que decir
que desde ese jardín de la casa mi madre
al que siempre que puedo volvemos
también escuchaba la radio muy típica en
esa época yo tengo ahora ya unos cuantos
años no quiero decir cuántos pero tengo
unos cuantos y escuchaba yo podría decir
ahora mi carro me lo robaron y ustedes
en la mente seguramente que se habrían
que melodía lo que sigue a continuación
nueva maría se fue buscando el sol en la
playa y yo estaba allí bueno iba al cole
hacia los deberes
escuchado la radio y decía este lindo no
me gusta pegarle me gusta estar y mucha
música española mucha música italiana
hace aproximadamente dos años tuve la
grandísima ocasión de poder satisfacer
una curiosidad que tenía desde entonces
que fue visitar los estudios de radio
televisión española en madrid en proveer
raid e ir al mismo sitio de donde se
emitían algunos de esos programas fue
una maravilla pues bien porque comentó
eso comentó eso porque sin darme yo
cuenta mientras crecía es a ese placer
de escuchar la radio se fue traduciendo
en una curiosidad por entender esa magia
cómo es posible que yo estudiaba una
clase de grafía que había un atlántico
de casi siete mil kilómetros entre la
habana y madrid por ejemplo y la onda
podría llegar y yo escuchaba ese sonido
tan bonito del asceta y de lola entonces
dije oye esto hay que estudiarlo creo yo
no y esto se estudia pues se estudia en
la universidad en la politécnica en que
vamos para allá y nos hicimos así en un
traje no res nos hicimos nos hicimos
nos hicimos ingeniero vale lo que me
pasó lo siguiente que eso sí yo no tenía
previsto es que esa pasión con las
telecomunicaciones
de pronto como dos ríos que se
encuentran en un punto de la vida
mientras estaba estudiando esas personas
esos maestros esas maestras que te
marcan no digo profesores maestras
maestros que te marcan me invitaron a
participar como alumno ayudante
preparando práctica de estas cosas para
mis propios compañeros me sorprendió de
pronto me di cuenta que esa pasión que
tenía por las telecomunicaciones empezó
a un poco entrar en contradicción con
una pasión por la enseñanza por suerte
soy una persona afortunada puedo decir
que he podido conjugar desde entonces
ambas pasiones siempre intentado como
docente es huir de enseñanzas metódicas
de enseñanzas que son mecánicas que
intentan uno aprender o enseñar
sintonizó la diapositiva que pueden ver
se refiere aún a algunos dibujos que
hizo un francés llama cote en el año
1890 aproximadamente donde le pidieron
imaginar cómo sería el año 2000 hizo
muchas entre otras cosas estaba volar a
la gente le encanta cuando hablan del
futuro volar volar
coches voladores robots que hacen cosas
os invito vuestra curiosidad que les
lleve a buscarlo en internet es
maravilloso entre todas ellas hay una
que me da un miedo tremendo y de la que
siempre he oído y es esa que aparece ahí
es esa escuela mecánica esa escuela sin
ton ni son siempre he pensado que cuando
estoy con esa arcilla maravillosa que es
las personas jóvenes a las que les
enseña nada una notita de nada es lo que
realmente se le puede enseñar porque el
conocimiento estos pastos tan vastos hay
que intentar fundamentar lo en la
curiosidad como un motor del pensamiento
reflexivo crítico donde a través de esa
curiosidad aprendamos ellos y nosotros
pues bien desde el año 2001 participó en
diferentes actividades que organizan
nuestra nuestra politécnica para
fomentar vocaciones estudiantes de
primaria estudiantes de secundaria
ciclos formativos estos estudiantes
estos jóvenes también vienen con sus
maestras con sus maestros con sus
orientadores pero yo realmente el
material de mi intención son ellos
siempre que puedo siempre que puedo voy
a los puntos por donde entran a la
escuela
a la universidad para esperarles si
puedo y pensé que tengo clase entonces
llamamos directamente la escuela pero si
puedo voy hasta ahí
y llegó y de un bienvenidos bienvenidos
y hacemos lo que les quiero proponer
ahora hagamos un pequeño paseo por este
maravilloso lugar que seguramente muchos
ya conocerán para los que era nuevo pues
bueno hace una gran suerte que este día
se lo haya permitido pues entonces le
digo vamos a entrar vamos a entrar a la
politécnica a entrar este fabuloso
campus de verano y eso lo que le
propongo a vosotros cuando entran
rápidamente se encuentran con unos
murales como unas grandes pinturas
algunas están en unas paredes otras
estás en otras si vuelven al año
siguiente es posible que algunas no
estén otras y bueno pues cuando entran a
modo de bienvenida junto con mis
palabras y ese pequeño paseo pues se
pueden encontrar unas pinturas que
producto de la labor de estudiantes de
la facultad de bellas artes que está en
esta politécnica que de hace tantísimos
años tiene una facultad de las artes
pionera en ese sentido en nuestro país
y artistas nacionales e internacionales
que vienen también a nuestro campus en
diferentes eventos es uno de ellos los
más famosos o el más conocido por ser
poliniza pues entonces hacen unos
dibujos que nos están mandando a través
de esa de ese arte fibra seguramente que
alguna reflexión un warning un oye es
importante que lo que estoy enseñas aquí
es muy importante que sea amplio que no
solamente sea técnico que no solamente
sea proyectos innovadores que intentan
estar muy bien pero también hay que
tener en cuenta la sostenibilidad el
medio ambiente la introducción en la
sociedad de las brechas que puede crear
la inclusión la solidaria la cooperación
y amistad que me gusta muchísimo cuando
llego a este maravilloso campus cada día
cuando llegue estas ediciones estos
diferentes eventos me gusta ver me gusta
entender y yo como observador tengo el
derecho de pensar que esos artistas nos
están diciendo algo a través de esa arte
fibra que durán en la gran mayoría de
las veces solamente un año
pues bien estos chicos que han llegado
quizás mirando uno le va diciendo mira
observa esto que te dice es muy
interesante y bueno nuestro camino va
siguiendo yo sé por donde quiero
llevarles el final es mi escuela de
teleco linda bella y vamos aquí pero si
podríamos ir por allá no solo por aquí
buenas definitivas si seguimos andando
no solamente es un perfecto y
maravilloso y bello lienzo este campus
deberá también los demás campus de la
politécnica no también hay esculturas
seguramente que sabrán que hay
diferentes museos aquí en la politécnica
y cuando uno entra empieza a cohabitar
entre las personas y entre estas dibujos
pues con diferentes esculturas hay más
de 75 de artistas tanto nacionales como
internacionales yo también tengo que
pensar que estos artistas nos tienen que
decir algo nos están diciendo algo a
gritos seguramente y yo intento en la
medida de lo posible llamar la atención
de estos chicos y llevarles por ejemplo
y yo pienso que cada cosa está puesta en
algún sitio específico no por gusto es
que yo soy así de curioso sabes y bueno
digo este tótem por decir algo el 75
no podría aquí estar hablando de las 75
piezas este tote uy este todo tenga al
lado de la biblioteca que quiera decir
cuando estos chicos y chicas esta
película también se la cuento a mis
estudiantes están estudiando y cuando
levantan la vista para descansar la
vista y miran y lo ven un tote punto t
si nos remontamos le pregunto a estos
chicos jóvenes que me viene que por
cierto vienen acelerado vienen con mucha
vitalidad y que ese es un tótem saca tu
móvil toda esta beta a todos entonces si
ya está bien bueno no importa que ahora
ya está fenomenal es una representación
de un grupo dice y dice se dice la rae
de que es una representación de un grupo
e indicó antiguamente se utilizaban
objetos naturales se utilizaban figuras
animales
y esto es mirar mirar pasar aquí esto es
pura tecnología aquí son antiguos
ordenadores que han quedado obsoletos ya
yo no sé si por la competencia por el
mercado quizás porque las prestaciones
mejoran quizás por una mezcla de todo
quizás por una obsolescencia planificada
programada percibida no lo sé y le va
soltando esas palabritas
aunque ellos no se quedan callados estos
chicos no se quedan callados enseguida
entran al toro entran al trapo enseguida
bueno ustedes se sienten representados
como grupo como etnia como tribu los
sentimos representados con ese trote wii
y es sí claro yo sí sí por cierto vamos
a seguir caminando porque no llegamos a
telesco vamos a seguir caminando y la
naturaleza donde se quedó donde esta
naturaleza donde están los animales no
está la sostenibilidad donde está la
madre que nos da soporte en este
universo tan maravilloso es el soporte
es el alimento ahí venimos y ahí
volvemos
te mira bueno no pasa red tú sigues
caminando eso seguramente que hacen su
trabajo etcétera bien cuando vas hacia
teleco a gesto y recorrido un poco largo
sabe pero bueno total ellos sacan su
bocadillo van comiendo tal pueden
definir tus revisas el whatsapp sigue y
si oye mira eso es lo que está ahí vamos
a ver qué nos cuenta el relativo que te
el bigote qué es eso que es eso no eso
es que son una pirámide como una
pirámide
es un obelisco así fijar fin a los
chicos
tampoco pasa nada le presta atención de
hecho ya están como un poquito picados a
esa altura sólo yo muchas veces y sé que
admira oye que tienen la base en la base
tiene la aritmética básica mis abuelos
desgraciadamente no pudieron estudiar
era ganar fa veto no sabía ni tan
siquiera eso después recuerdo que mis
padres pudieron tener una alfabetización
de la aritmética pero ya yo no estaba
así yo ya estaba un poquito más allá y
entonces en esa obra maravillosa doctor
mallorquín he visto que encima de esa
pirámide están los ordenadores
nuevamente ahí ya verificados para
siempre ceros y unos que jamás va a
volver a circular como electrones o con
fotones en un ordenador bien y arriba
que hay arriba que hay arriba
limpia una superficie metal puro metal
ojalá pudiera vivir mil años me gustaría
saber cuál es el próximo paso pero ya no
lo puedo hacer ya me duelen las piernas
sabe la lumbalgia vosotros ustedes de
chicos que quieren que vine arriba
te dan respuestas se puede ser un libro
un paper jcr creíble ellos no se habían
callado sabes que viene por cierto no lo
va a ser yo lo va a hacer vosotros
por cierto voy a intentar en la medida
de lo posible enseñarte a ver si puedo
enseñarte en un futuro que todavía no ha
llegado eso se impactó con unos pasos
anteriores me voy a subir en unos
hombros de gigantes para llegar más
lejos los bueno seguimos caminando a
veces llegamos a teleco porque se nos
acaba el día etcétera se nos acaba el
tiempo acá y al final llegamos a telecom
veía escuelas precios que te encuentras
a menudo rollo dos antenas parabólicas
yo solo decir parábolas pero es unas
antenas parabólicas llegué enseguida de
cómo los chavales unos se van para
tussam para acá lo que son más
espabilados se van a que está más cerca
lo que estás un poco así y medio
dormidos se van a la más lejos porque ya
no hay sitio porque yo le he dicho que a
un grupo de dos dividir entre 12 bueno
en definitiva y ahí están los chicos
los estoy observando por cierto es una
clase de recursos humanos perfectas
porque pasa lo que acabo de comentar los
que están un poco más al alki te van a
adelante y los que se quedaron van atrás
pero entonces empiezan si hay alguien se
es callar los cahiers haya rescatado a
ver vosotros primero hablamos porque
vamos a subir una transmisión y ustedes
se callan y dice ahí está la líder esa
la jefa es a partir de ahora a esto me
la llevo yo maravilloso bueno entonces
le dice parábola igual que al cuadrado
rollo doctor che troll deja eso es
parábola y x al cuadrado se abre se
cierra se desplaza la palabra se abre se
mueve una aplicación matemática la
física la comunicación no por eso la
tenemos aquí en nuestra cueva hay veces
que te dice y esto me entristece mucho
la wta el pc que te dicen no siempre
producen cuando sale dice en la escuela
aprendemos cada cosa opción para nada
la escuela anteriores uy profe me está
escuchando no se sabe que son los chicos
si le enseñan cosas maravillosas
estudian la parábola estudian los
principios de transmisión a través del
espacio libre solo es que hay que
intentar ver que ustedes saben todo eso
todo ese conocimiento ustedes son
afortunados que saben tantas cosas yo lo
sé porque mis hijas estudian y me quedo
alucinado con todo el conocimiento que
recibe lo que pasa es que de vez en
cuando hay que decirles y si lo sabes
claro que lo sabes mira aquí tenemos una
tienes aquí
una aplicación práctica por cierto vamos
a entrar porque el sol pica
aquí hay 300 días en esta tierra
valenciana maravillosa 300 días de sol
100% sol
entonces quitas el mes de vacaciones
vamos a entrar y mientras vamos
caminando les propongo que vayamos
caminando y elevemos un poco la vista
como todos son muy jóvenes tienen buena
vista aquí arriba allí arriba en la
esquinita hay un pararrayos yo le digo
entonces sabrían explicar qué cosas es
que sepa lo que estáis un pararrayos
interesante sabios de la antigüedad pero
sabio sabio de los sócrates and company
no sabría explicar lo que es un
pararrayos bueno dirían que se uno sé
que ustedes embargo si sabe entonces vas
caminando y le dicen cinco que ustedes
son unos cracks
y hay que la línea y saber que
existe lo bueno y al final hemos pasado
por cierto cuando ya está llegando hemos
cogido por este ladito así la escuela el
edificio la entrada está un poquito más
allá y que hace un pequeño giro que os
propongo que la hagáis y tal le digo yo
por ciento mira che para sabio que hemos
dejado detrás me has visto películas
romanos los 300 los que se han resistido
a esos tíos grandes con una ellos saben
que tienen unos cascos con unas cositas
arriba esos peto esos seis pack
que no se ven pero se intuye que hay tal
el peso faldita esas sandalias todo 100%
metálico puro es hay una relación en
ningún evento raro
pero sobre todo la lana
una danza bueno el que estudia historia
ellos lo saben
sí lo sé que yo ya no lo sé muy bien
pero ellos se ponían unos delante otros
extras con unas lanzas más largas buenos
de crítica sólo tienes hacia arriba es
un pararrayos
imagínate por lo que no es una tarde y
chucky y matthew lo aquí hay esperando a
que vengan los persas oye venga con la
lanza así hay que estar al loro con la
lanza de este no deje la lanza tirada
porque vienen los personajes y entonces
de pronto se perdió uno yo estoy seguro
que se pierden en las películas no salen
sócrates gun company no lo pone la
ilíada no está pero se entienden y
entonces se dice gracias gracias gracias
gracias
i
y te dice uno que está ahí espabilado
curioso la curiosidad siempre ha
existido siempre siempre siempre
el rey hay una tragedia por ahí yo creo
que esto no tiene que ver con su colega
yo me doy cuenta que cada vez que uno
sube el pincho este y se nubla aquí se
pide la gente y éste dijo mira tira
p'alante web en definitiva que estamos
caminando estamos conversando estamos
aprendiendo ellos y yo soy el que más
aprende porque ellos son 25-30 ellos
vienen sus distintas casas cada vez yo
aprendo y me quedo conoce la película se
la cuenta a los otros entonces esto va
creciendo y creciendo y creciendo bueno
llegamos al final a mi escuela preciosa
llegas allí bueno está un poco sudado
cansado no sé qué creo que hemos
aprendido muchas cosas de manera no
formal de manera informal sonriendo y yo
lo pudiera evaluar
porque eso es lo que no se evalúa se
devalúa no las evaluaciones en tampa
a fin fenomenal pues a lo mejor habría
que ampliar eso bien ya esta gente le
culé y se escucha balón a cada
generación interna de nación cepta creo
que se llama vamos a mandar no aquí un
self y con esto
sabrían no saben un tuit en internet un
hashtag este troll este tío
hemos entrado a un maravilloso museo las
telecomunicaciones llamados vicente
miráis ahora nuestro primer ingeniero
valenciano que tiene muchísimas piezas
muchas muchas muchas dejo que vuestra
curiosidad les lleve hasta ahí tiene una
página web excelente hay realidad
aumentada para ver el funcionamiento de
un gramófono de una central telefónica
es bueno cómo nos hacemos aquí un self y
interesante ven acá una pregunta y cómo
funcionaba la gente antes oye no no
estaremos metiendo demasiado en las
redes y de paso le da un poquito de caña
esto esto va por buen camino está
obsolescencia esto estos teléfonos que
cada dos años yo no sé cómo se empiezan
a caer solo de las mesas y se rompen
ahí les dejo bien en definitiva es un es
un es un paseo a mi verdad que me gusta
muchísimo como comentó cuando lo empiezo
a hacer siempre que puedo se los
recomiendo mis estudiantes de máster he
estado hace poco estudiante de máster en
música haciendo esto porque al final de
la jornada toda la música por
sintetizador estas cosas tuvo como base
las telecomunicaciones sabes es una
delicia la verdad de carrera bien le
digo mira allí vamos a ver 180 grados
aquí hay que tener mucho cuidado con las
cosas matemáticos que aquí la peña sabe
de 180 grados
mucho cuidado
y en severa nuestra escuela nuestra
universidad como parte de esa enseñanza
de la que yo siento integral e inclusiva
son dos palabras muy distintas
esa enseñanza donde los estudiantes
pueden venir tienen accesibilidad esa es
un poco la que intentó llevar a la clase
creo que como profesor que aspiró algún
día poder ser un maestro porque lo digo
con la boca muy muy muy pequeña no tiene
por qué ser un aula en cuatro paredes de
un calendario de clase un peor puede ser
en cualquier momento y eso es un poco lo
que intento decirle a estos chavales
mira el verbo mirar observa y si tienes
un poquito de curiosidad
seguramente que tú y yo nosotros vamos a
aprender mucho más muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]